son las siete de la mañana en los
suburbios de heider abad estos
espectadores se levantaron al Alba para
venir a esta sala de cine y asistir al
estreno de esta nueva superproducción
regional una película de espías
protagonizada por una estrella local
favorito nunca nos perdemos el estreno
de una de sus películas
es mi héroe vengo temprano aquí y
después me voy a trabajar
el entusiasmo se siente desde que se
apagan las luces
[Aplausos]
a 800 kilómetros de bombay meca del cine
en India las películas del Sur del país
prosperan filmadas en tamil nadú en
kerala o incluso aquí en el estado de
telangana en 2022 generaron 860 millones
de dólares lo equivalente a la mitad de
los ingresos de toda la Industria
cinematográfica del país un récord hasta
entonces los largometrajes indios de
bollywood filmados en lengua hindi
dominaban Las taquillas del país en
estos estudios situados en el corazón de
jaider abad las películas son filmadas
en telugo la lengua regional hablada por
casi 100 millones de habitantes después
son dobladas para ser proyectadas en el
resto del país pudimos asistir al rodaje
de la próxima película de acción del
actor pero filmar a la estrella está
prohibido para mantener el efecto
sorpresa en la gran pantalla según el
director las películas de Hollywood
tienen algo único En comparación con las
comedias románticas
de bollywood nos gustan las películas
fuera de lo común nuestros personajes
son superhéroes por lo general al
comienzo de la película es un hombre
común y corriente pero primero se
convierte en un héroe y después se
transforma en un superhéroe y las
escenas de acción deben ser increíbles
historias menos elitistas más populares
esa sería la fórmula mágica de Hollywood
a 50 kilómetros de ahí están los
estudios de raji son los más grandes del
mundo 800 hectáreas de escenarios de
grabación que van desde una estación de
tren hasta edificios religiosos pasando
por las calles típicas del norte de
India lo más atractivo para Los
visitantes son los escenarios de la saga
en dos partes bajo Bali uno de los
mayores éxitos en la historia del cine
indio la historia cuenta la guerra entre
dos primos por la conquista de un reino
en una India medieval cuarenta millones
de dólares de presupuesto miles de
extras y efectos especiales
primera vez vistos en una producción
local las locaciones donde se rodó la
película se han convertido en un lugar
de peregrinación para los fanáticos
las películas del sur porque en ellas
veo mi identidad Mis raíces bollywood no
me dice nada
aquí al menos no copiamos los escenarios
o las películas de otros países o de
otras regiones tenemos nuestras propias
historias
el hombre detrás del éxito de esta
epopeya épica es el director rayamully
ahora conocido en el mundo entero
junto con su compositor este año obtuvo
el Oscar a mejor canción original por la
película triple Erick otro largometraje
en telúgu en el que se refleja la
diversidad del país
me parece algo maravilloso porque no
existe ningún otro país del mundo
solo India tiene tantas lenguas
ahora muchas personas en el mundo saben
que la Industria del cine en India no
sólo se limita a las películas de
bollywood en indie se producen muchas
otras películas en otros idiomas y
cuando los espectadores se dan cuenta de
que mis películas están en telúbu me
siento muy orgulloso
una consecuencia inesperada del éxito de
las películas de rayamully es que cada
vez más actores debutantes tratan de
empezar su carrera en el sur del país en
esta escuela de cine la cantidad de
alumnos se ha duplicado en tan solo
cinco años soy su novia Desde hace dos
años quién eres Qué estás haciendo aquí
escuchen les voy a explicar todo qué vas
a decir así de qué se trata todo esto en
un medio tan competitivo tollywood le da
la oportunidad a esta nueva generación
de confiar en sus posibilidades
en bombay aunque pases una audición y te
acepten no es seguro que obtengas un
papel al final te dicen que le darán el
rol a una pequeña celebridad o a un
miembro de tal o tal familia del medio
aquí en las audiciones a las que he ido
los seleccionadores eran respetuosos y
muy tranquilos me dieron una oportunidad
y me seleccionaron para un pequeño papel
en una película
dificultad para entrar en el medio falta
de originalidad en los últimos años la
industria cinematográfica de habla hindi
que tanto ha hecho soñar a la población
ha sido blanco de críticas las grandes
estrellas
no son taquilleras salvo contadas
excepciones todos sus últimos
largometrajes han sido fracasos pero
bollywood está tratando de recuperarse
reclutar actores o actrices de Lugo
claramente tiene el objetivo de
aprovechar ese mercado los que encabezan
la Industria del cine en bombay saben
muy bien que esas personas son estrellas
y que sus admiradores están dispuestos a
hacer todo por ellas y quieren
Reproducir eso Entonces si pueden
contratarlas para sus películas lo harán
sin dudarlo además el auge de las
plataformas de streaming como Netflix o
Amazon han permitido a millones de
indios acceder a otro tipo de películas
esto ha hecho que ahora el público sea
todavía más exigente